Psychiatry placement at Medical School
[Music]
I didn't think it would take this kind
of time
and give you an exclusive tour
[Music]
thank you
good morning today is my first day of
two-week Psychiatry placement at Medical
School I checked the timetable for the
week and it's actually quite full-on I
need to be at the hospital at 8 45 this
morning and we finish at 5 00 PM so it's
going to be a long day for me anyway my
flatmates are still sleeping so I don't
want to be too loud in the kitchen let's
prepare our breakfast then go do some
work
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
for today I've been told to revise
psychiatric history taking which means
going through how to talk to patients
with mental health problems and what to
ask them so that's what I've been doing
so far because I'm going to be at the
hospital all day long now I'm gonna pack
some lunch to take with me
[Music]
by the time I finish doing this I didn't
know what I wanted me
thank you
love you how are you feeling about
starting psych good should be uh
interesting couple of weeks so let's see
what happens
So the plan for this morning is to have
a like teach and then have a board round
it's so awkward isn't it you're Alfred
you see that
hi this is Lavi welcome to my YouTube
channel hello
um so today we are going to our psych
placement
and
there you go that was good that was very
good
Elizabeth have a feeling about being on
site
we'll see what there is to come yeah
that's exactly what Lavi said she said
exact same thing interestingly
[Music]
in the morning we had the board round
which is where doctors nurses care
workers all come together to review the
progress of patience and whilst waiting
for the psychiatrist I did some editing
in the staff room lastly in this room I
talked to a patient with schizophrenia
it's almost two o'clock and now I'm
going to have my lunch
[Music]
thank you
amk results around they are indeed by
the way amk is the exam that we have
four times a year it's basically
multiple choice knowledge exam
Wi-Fi doesn't want to connect for some
reason
I'm just gonna hotspot it yeah
okay thank God yeah I'm fine I'm fast
it's actually the highest Mark I ever
got so far
oh I've paid off yeah
thank you
do we know the average we have 61. is it
no way I'm not sure if I'm going to I'm
going to shall I share my score I think
I might thankfully I'm well above the
average I'm quite happy about this but
you know I don't want to just obviously
share the good moments there are times
that I am not satisfied with my grades
as well but this is one of the happy
moments that I want to cherish basically
[Music]
thank you
be responsible just in case if it's
positive I'm crying I would cry because
I would not be able to go to CrossFit of
course it's not about placement I mean
placement as well so you're having a
cool week I'm in sexual health but
CrossFit oh my God yeah it's supposed to
do may I knew it oh my god wow
guys you put it on the group chat
make a test take a test take a test I'm
gonna look up the the guidelines
[Music]
it's just like Robert crying though it's
because whenever I put this stick this
up my nose I cry this is so bad yeah I
didn't think it would take this kind of
turn you know I didn't think it would be
actually positive
do you know the guideline yeah oh my God
I'm so glad I tested negative I'm gonna
stay away from everyone just in case
[Music]
good morning this is four days later on
a Friday today we have lots of teaching
sessions at the hospital and I've got
some work to catch up on so I thought
I'd show you how I organize my tasks at
the start of each day using notion and
give you an exclusive tour so notion is
the app that you see in almost all of my
Vlogs and I've been getting lots of
comments on it so I'm so grateful to be
working with them thank you to notion
for sponsoring this part of the video so
notion is this incredible planning tool
and organization system my absolute
productivity platform you can do
everything from to-do list to take notes
to collaborate everything you can
imagine is in one platform so welcome to
the home page of my notion I love that
you can personalize it however you want
to make it your own I'm on notion every
single day without a fail that's why I
spread some motivational quotes
throughout my page for example enjoy the
journey balance or if we scroll down
under my planner I've got it's never too
late to start now for your future self
so feel free to use any of these if it
resonates with you or you can make it
your own so I split my whole life into
two on this home page on the right I
I've got all my University related and
admin work organized on the left I have
YouTube and Instagram and of course my
favorite part of this page is this
planner slash to-do list the notion has
this template feature which saves so
much time when I click on this new week
it automatically creates a new weekly
spread so I don't need to copy and paste
a new spread each week so on Mondays I
just select and delete the previous one
and start fresh with a new week also I
have this calendar widget on the side
and at the bottom which helps me a lot
to navigate any exams or deadlines
coming up notion is completely free for
students and Educators you can sign up
by using the link in the description box
down below if you're not already using
notion once you see all the options that
you can have it can feel overwhelming
but honestly if you just spent couple of
minutes to download it and start with
Basics and builds up on it with time it
will serve you well it's a learning
curve and there are still some functions
that I didn't get to try out yet but
even the most basic version of notion is
absolutely worth it we're on our way to
the lectures
the outfit
[Music]
thank you
the rain still tickets on Tuesday we
just finished for tutorials now we're
going shopping what were you up to this
morning yeah in the morning I was trying
to get Beyonce tickets okay so you
skipped them for Beyonce too I didn't
even get the tickets at the end so like
it wasn't worth it
[Music]
but you pass through your MK I'm so
proud of you
actually you're wrapping the medical
school now yeah
[Music]
just getting my favorite pesto I mean
not favorite but it's very cheap so
[Music]
do you want to help now it's all right
I'll just keep it all for you okay
[Music]
just finished having my dinner now I'm
meeting a friend in the library to do
some questions on psychiatry
[Music]
my legs are aching why is that we
haven't walked that much well I did walk
all the way to the hospital for lectures
[Music]
thank you
I'm tired yeah nothing underground
really yeah
I haven't done that much yet did some
questions on Psychiatry I didn't do as
many questions as I would like to but I
realized I better go to sleep now
what did you do you like money on
well too bad
anyway so yeah I didn't do as many
questions as I would like to but I'd
rather sleep early and do it in the
morning so that's what I'm going to do
but I hope you guys enjoyed this
consider subscribing and I'll see you in
the next one bye
all right